(gentle instrumental music)
- When a patient first
comes to our office,
they feel a little self-conscious
about the way they look,
or they don't wanna
look people eye to eye.
People always think,
"I'm just doing this
for cosmetic reasons,"
but actually it's the
restoration of the person.
(gentle instrumental music)
I'm an ocularist.
That is someone that fits and fabricates
artificial eyes for people.
(gentle instrumental music)
During the surgery to remove your eye,
the doctors place an
implant in the muscle crown,
so we fit a concave, convex shape
that sits like a contact
lens on the implant.
It is an art form.
We do everything by hand.
First we take an impression.
This gives us an imprint
of the exact structures
behind the eyelids.
Painting is very challenging.
Everything starts from a black disk,
and everything is painted on top of that.
It's very difficult to
match the iris color.
No two people have the same color,
so we'll sit there with a paint brush,
and we'll paint different structures,
dots, dashes, striations,
overlay that with different hues
or different saturations of color
to give it the three dimensional effect
that we see in people's natural eyes.
(gentle instrumental music)
Part of what makes it look natural
is to have the sparkle in your eye.
We do that with fine polishing
and fine tuning the curves
of the artificial eye.
The part I most like about
fabricating a prosthesis
is when I've finished it,
and I look at it,
and I see the illusion
that I've just created.
When somebody loses their eye,
sometimes they feel like they've lost
part of their self-being.
We make them feel whole again
and confident to take on the world.
(gentle instrumental music)